back to the future storyline ranges from
2015 to 1885.
marty mcfly our fearless teen hero
unites these different eras alongside
doc brown in his fabulous time traveling
delorean
this results in one seriously tangled
timeline so we're here to unravel
marty's story from beginning
to end marty mcfly is a typical teen
he dreams of rock stardom he has a
devoted girlfriend named jennifer
and he fears ending up like his parents
while he often gets in trouble at school
for being a slacker
he's not a bad kid he's just restless
[Music]
marty lives in hill valley california
with his family
alcoholic mother lorraine cowardly
father george older brother dave and his
older sister linda
no one in the family is terribly happy
under the thumb of his abusive boss
biff tannen george is especially
miserable
the whole mcfly family is in a rut
having little ambition
few accomplishments and weak connections
to each other
so it's no wonder marty sought out the
companionship of doc brown
dr emmett brown is what one might call a
mad scientist a genius inventor doc
brown creates a time machine based on a
delorean
marty is his assistant and friend often
helping with his experiments
since his dad is kind of a sad sack doc
is a father figure to marty
just a very weird one marty and doc
brown's relationship might seem strange
at first glance
what guitar shredding teen hangs out
with a weirdo inventor
back to the future co-creator bob gale
explains for years
marty was told that doc brown was
dangerous a crackpot a lunatic
so being a red-blooded american teenage
boy he decided to find out just why this
guy was so dangerous
marty snuck into doc's lab and was
fascinated by all the cool stuff
that was there when doc found him there
he was delighted to find that marty
thought he was cool
and accepted him for what he was the
plot of the first back to the future
movie revolves around marty's jump
back to the year 1955 after doc
introduces marty to the time machine
he explains that it's powered by
plutonium which he stole from libyan
terrorists
when the terrorists come to collect in a
blaze of gunfire marty escapes and docks
time machine
deposited in 1955 marty seeks out a
young doc brown
the two hatch a plan to get marty back
to the future
using the time machine and a bolt of
lightning set to hit the famed hill
valley clock tower later that week
fearing that marty might influence
future events doc insists that marty
stay
out of sight but it's already too late
marty managed to alter his own future in
a major way by interacting with his
father and biff
first he got in a fight with the young
version of biff then he
inadvertently sabotaged his parents own
marriage when he followed george
how lorraine baines and george mcfly
fell in love is a bit of a weird story
as marty's parents tell it george fell
from a tree and got hit by a car
driven by lorraine's dad he's a peeping
tom
mr baines brought george inside to
recover and lorraine fell
head over heels in love at least that's
how the story went before time traveling
marty came along
and the altered timeline marty pushes
george out of the way of the car getting
hit by
it himself mr baines brings marty inside
and marty's own mother develops the hots
for him
whoa wait wait a minute doc are you
trying to tell me that my mother
has got the hots for me precisely whoa
this is heavy
so not only do marty and doc have to get
marty back to the future
they also have to find a way to get
george and lorraine back together
they encounter multiple hurdles along
the way including resistance from
lorraine
reluctance from george and interference
from biff
thankfully marty and doc succeed and
marty heads back to the future
not only is his family intact marty's
involvement has made george much more
confident lorraine healthier and his
siblings more successful
marty's life looks pretty good thanks to
his trip back to 1955
but as the first film ends doc returns
from the future
he says he's been to 2015 and while
marty and jennifer are fine
their future children are not marty and
jennifer hop into delorean and head to
2015 for back to the future part two
the hill valley of 2015 looks much like
the hill valley of 1985
only with hoverboards 3d advertising and
an 80s themed cafe
marty meets his own son marty jr and
then runs into biff's grandson
griff griff is just as abusive as his
grandfather
pressuring marty jr into robbing a bank
as doc discovered
the heist lands marty jr in jail marty
prevents the robbery and griff winds up
in jail instead
sadly 1985 marty discovers his future
isn't so bright
following a car accident he trades his
rockstar dreams for a soul-sucking
corporate job
marty doc and an unconscious jennifer
returned to 1985 with renewed
determination
with doc swearing to destroy the
troublesome time machine
when doc and marty return to 1985 they
find a much changed
jennifer's home has bars on the windows
marty's house is full of strangers
and hill valley has become overrun with
gambling drinking
and general debauchery doc and marty
soon learned that the old biff from 2015
stole the delorean while they were
distracted and traveled back in time
hoping to get a leg up on the future
biff gives his 1955 self a sports
almanac from the year 2000
armed with decades of future sports
scores biff
gambles his way into a massive fortune
and some serious power
old biff's scheme creates an alternate
1985.
biff is now a millionaire married to
marty's physically enhanced mom
and george mcfly is dead marty soon
discovers that biff had george murdered
and forced lorraine to marry him with
doc out of the way
committed to an insane asylum biff used
his wealth to take control of the whole
town
a symbol of his sleazy empire tannen's
garish casino stands in place of hill
valley's courthouse
faced with fixing this mess doc and
marty head back to 1955
and stopped biff from giving his younger
self the almanac
they can't travel back to 2015 to do it
as doc explains
because the 2015 of 1985 a's future
won't be the same one from which they
just returned
heavy right so the duo heads to 1955
where doc hasn't been since he lived it
the first time marty however
was there just the day before doc and
marty are faced with a delicate
situation
they have to track down biff and nab the
almanac while trying not to get caught
by their other selves
at this point there are two docs and two
marties in 1955.
marty whatever happens you must not let
your other self see you the consequences
could be disastrous
excuse me sir young doc is setting up
the lightning rod on the clock tower
while marty number one is busy getting
his parents back together
old doc and back to the future part
two's maine marty managed to relieve
biff of the almanac and burn it
destroying the 1985
a timeline in which biff became a
millionaire but marty and doc aren't in
the clear yet
they still have to return to their own
1985 to see if their plan worked
while marty number two and old doc tried
to get back to 1985
the storm this sent marty number one
back to the future in the first movie
rages
the delorean piloted by old doc is
struck by
lightning hurling it into the past marty
number two stranded in 1955
faces an uncertain future moments later
a western union agent bearing a
70-year-old letter addressed to marty
appears
the letters from doc having been hurled
back to 1885
doc now lives as a blacksmith and has
hidden the delorean away from marty
number two to find and use to get back
to 1985.
the second film ends with marty number
two hilariously approaching the younger
doc
who has just sent marty number one back
to 1985. okay relax doc it's me it's me
it's martin
oh i can't just send you back to the
future oh i know you did send me back to
the future but i'm back
i'm back from the future when marty in
1950s doc
digged the delorean out of the cave
where old west dock hit it
they discovered something about doc's
time in the past that makes marty want
to abandon their plan
doc's letter detailed that he was
perfectly happy living in 1885
and that marty shouldn't come to get him
but marty then stumbles upon doc's
gravestone in a nearby cemetery
it is dated six days after doc wrote the
letter and reveals that doc was murdered
by biff's ancestor
buford mad dog tannen marty has no
choice
but to travel back to 1885 and rescue
doc
but after arriving in the past and
reconnecting with the doc who's been
living there
the delorean's gas tank is damaged
leaving marty and doc without their
usual means of transport
trapped in the past doc and marty hatch
a plan to rig the delorean to a
locomotive to get the machine up to the
88 miles per hour it needs to travel
through time
before marty went back to 1885 he read
on doc's tombstone that the stone was
erected by doc's beloved clara
but when marty arrives doc has no idea
who clara is
as marty and doc planned their escape
from 1885 a runaway buggy catches their
attention
they rescue the passenger the town's new
school teacher
from falling into a ravine she
introduces herself as clara clayton
and the sparks between her and doc are
immediate marty explains that the ravine
clara almost fell into becomes known as
the clayton ravine
named for a schoolteacher who fell in
100 years ago
by rescuing her doc and marty altered
the timeline
though marty considers it no big deal
the incident intensifies doc's desire to
destroy the infernal machine
while in 1885 marty gets a chance to
meet some of his ancestors
he stays for a while on the farm of
sheamus and maggie mcfly
two irish immigrants who have settled in
the old west he also meets their infant
son
his great-grandfather william marty
tells them his name is clint eastwood
so as not to cause any confusion also
present in 1885 is beaufort mad
dog tannen the ancestor of biff and
griff tannen
who is just as awful as you'd expect a
drunken thief bank robber and murderer
mad dog sets his sights on killing doc
over 80 dollars in a faulty horseshoe
marty and biff's ancestors both reside
in the hill valley of 1885
but we don't get to see any brown
relatives as doc's family immigrated in
1908
still the idea that the tannins have
bullied the mcflies for
100 years is a legacy marty hopes to
finally end
by agreeing to duel mad dog himself
marty successfully saves doc's life
the two also managed to get the delorean
rigged up to the train
but an accident nearly kills clara our
heroes get it together at the last
minute
delivering marty back to 1985 just in
time for the delorean to be smashed
by an oncoming train there he finds
jennifer exactly where he left her
hill valley is as it should be with an
area tin and casino or a mysterious
tombstone to be found
while driving jennifer back to the spot
where the time machine was destroyed
marty narrowly avoids the car accident
that derails his future life
suddenly a 19th century locomotive
flashes onto the tracks with doc at the
helm
he's turned the train into a time
machine and travels through time with
clara
now his wife and their two boys jules
and vern
doc explains before they fly off that
marty and jennifer's fate isn't written
yet
they still have control over their lives
despite what they've seen and heard in
the future
and the past
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about back to
the future are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]